what are the trends in the school choice
movement in new jersey well in charter
schools I'm concerned about it because
the Christie administration just also
authorized three new charter schools for
New Jersey for next year out of 38
applications I'm concerned that one
state is populist as New Jersey is has
so few charter schools compared to other
areas in the country and it seems like
there's a a resistance to the growth of
this it's pretty firm and in New Jersey
I'd like you to talk to us a little bit
about the public school system in perth
amboy and what is the amount of money
spent per student in this area it is
about twenty-two thousand dollars five
hundred twenty two thousand five hundred
dollars per student right so that's an
insane amount of money for the results
that we're getting currently our
graduation rate is somewhere around
fifty seven percent which rivals Camden
New Jersey we do have a charter school
in Perth my I'm the graduation rate is
higher they're testing at higher levels
and they're doing it at half the price
no one ever gets into the nuts and bolts
on the hardwired deep in equities
important than for people to understand
that like not every charter school is
great just like that every district the
traditional district school is great but
the good thing about charter schools
that are not great is that we can close
them so there's 87 open charter schools
right now in New Jersey there have been
nearly 20 schools that had been closed
in the last 20 years for charter schools
which is a very very high percent
compared to other states are the rumors
true would there be a check offered at
some point yes oh yeah I've committed to
starting the startup Education
Foundation whose first project will be a
hundred million dollar challenge grant
100 million dollar in 2010 facebook CEO
mark zuckerberg actually gave a hundred
million dollars to new up to help the
schooling system but 31 million of that
was actually used to retro actively give
unionized teachers a pay rise do you
think that this is a reflection of some
of the problems within the schooling
system at the moment certainly it's it's
complex issue because there are those
who would say there are education reform
advocates in school choice advocates who
will say that one transitional tool we
can use to somehow get to a better area
where the real is real teacher
evaluation in real school choice is to
just buy off the union's just write them
a check pay them off is the one way that
they'll make some concessions when it
comes to negotiations with regards to
some of the stuff that we want and so it
has been argued that that was part of a
formula Newark also now has actually a
more robust teacher evaluation plan than
the rest of New Jersey and why Newark
though because you know what's your
relationship with NORC well Newark is
really just because I believe in these
guys right one of the things I think you
can really argue in Newark fairly
strenuously is that at twenty four
thousand dollars a kid and thirteen
thousand dollars a kid for pre-k and a
billion dollar budget all together that
we have enough money so as much as I was
supportive of the gift it did kind of
miss the important part of that
discussion which is that like you could
have all the money in the world if you
don't have the right leaders in the
schools with the families don't have the
right choices if you're not deliberately
hiring the best teachers you cannot
support now can i get rid of the bad
ones you don't have a great leader you
got one hundred million dollars with the
same [ __ ] show really being probably the
only school choice member on the board
you know I do take a lot of flak for
that a lot of these teachers are a few
of them that I went to school with you
know any kind of see me as like stabbing
them in the back and you know I just try
to stay on message which is you know
this is about the students and the
parents being able to have a choice you
have to switch your philosophy in my
opinion and and more and more people are
around the country but the idea is
really the money is not for a building
or a group of adults or bureaucracy or
administration it's for the children's
education that is what people are used
to schools are about convenience and
comfort what we are doing is not about
convenience and comfort is about
necessity and freedom and survival and
we have to figure out ways to
communicate that better and I want to
argue all of this stuff like is as bad
as it looks it has to happen we have to
fake we can't get better the
conversation we can't get better doing
any of it if we
try it